This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The term hijacking goes back to Probition days. When gangsters would stop trucks carrying moonshine, and they come up to the guy in the cab with their pistol and point in their face and say, hold your hands high, Jack, and they take all the liquor and drive off with the truck. But in the early days of commercial air travel, the thought that someone would hijack a plane was scarcely even considered.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。“劫机”这个词可以追溯到禁酒令时期。当时歹徒们会拦截运送私酒的卡车，他们走到驾驶室里的人面前，用手枪指着他们的脸说：“杰克，把手举高，”然后他们抢走所有的酒，开着卡车扬长而去。但在商业航空旅行的早期，有人会劫持飞机的想法几乎都没人考虑过。
When they created government oversight of aviation in 1958, the congressional law that did that did not make hijacking a crime. Because no one had foreseen that anyone in a country like America, where theoretically, if you wanted to go somewhere, you could just buy a ticket to go there. No one assumed that any American would ever do this. And Brendan Eicharner, author of The Skies Belong to Us, Love, Interror, and the Golden Age of hijacking says that the design of airport terminals reflected that.
当他们在1958年创建政府航空监管机构时，为此制定的国会法律并没有将劫机定为犯罪。因为没有人预见到，在像美国这样的国家里，理论上如果你想去某地，你只要买张票去就行了。没有人会假设任何美国人会做出这种事。《蓝天属于我们：爱、恐怖与劫机黄金时代》的作者布伦丹·伊查纳表示，机场航站楼的设计反映了这一点。
It's hard to fathom now, but you could literally get out of a taxi at the curb and walk through the terminal, walk onto the tarmac to the top of the boarding stairs and sometimes onto the plane itself without a ticket, without showing anyone your identification, certainly without anyone searching your person or your luggage in any
现在很难想象，但你过去真的可以直接从路边的出租车下来，穿过航站楼，走到停机坪上登机梯的顶端，有时甚至可以直接走上飞机，不需要机票，不需要向任何人出示身份证件，当然更不需要任何人对你的人身或行李进行任何形式的
way, shape, or form. So it was very much similar to getting on a train when that was by design by the airlines. Then starting in 1961, an epidemic of hijackings began. It really wasn't epidemic, and I mean that in saying that the virus, the behavioral virus mutated over time, were kind of the basic features of these hijackings changed. The first phase of skyjackers all wanted passage to Cuba. May 1st, 1961 was the first American hijacking perpetrated by Antulio Ramirez Ortiz.
搜查。所以这在很大程度上类似于坐火车，这也是航空公司刻意设计的。然后从1961年开始，劫机潮爆发了。它其实不是一种流行病，我的意思是说这种病毒、行为病毒随着时间发生了变异，这些劫机事件的基本特征发生了变化。第一批空中劫机者都要求去古巴。1961年5月1日是安图利奥·拉米雷斯·奥尔蒂斯实施的第一起美国劫机事件。
He was kind of a somewhat mentally disturbed electrician in Miami who got on a Key Westbound flight and announced With a holding a knife to the pilot's throat that he had been hired to assassinate Castro Vidal Castro and wanted to go there to warn Castro about this In the second phase the sky-jackers broadened their horizons to more crew and passengers of the Forest Hikejack incident involving a U.S. air liner. In the second phase, the skyjackers broadened their horizons to more distant lands. My favorite example is a man named Rafael Minicielo, who was an Italian-American Marine who actually went from Los Angeles to Rome, where he was hell as a hero upon landing and actually ended up only doing 18 months in prison because the time refused to extradite him or actually charge him with hijacking.
他有点像是迈阿密精神有点失常的电工，他登上一架开往基韦斯特的航班，把一把刀架在飞行员喉咙上，宣称他被雇去暗杀卡斯特罗·维达尔·卡斯特罗，想要去那里警告卡斯特罗。在第二阶段，劫机者将视野扩大到更多的机组人员和乘客——这是涉及美国客机的森林劫机事件。在第二阶段，劫机者将视野扩大到了更遥远的土地。我最喜欢的例子是一个叫拉斐尔·米尼切洛的人，他是一个意大利裔美国海军陆战队员，他实际上从洛杉矶飞到了罗马，落地时被奉为英雄，最后实际上只坐了18个月的牢，因为当地拒绝引渡他或实际指控他劫机。
And he actually ended up after that, signing a contract to start a spaghetti western film. Very good looking guy. Then Skyjacker's morphed into classic kidnappers, demanding ransom. The man who started this was a man named Arthur Gates Berkeley, an unemployed truck driver who had to dispute with the IRS and he actually hijacked a plane from Phoenix to Washington, DC where he demanded $100 million in cash to be given to him about the Supreme Court because he was in rage they hadn't taken his tax case. So that kind of set off this last phase of the epidemic where people started asking for tons of money and gold bars and crates of liquor and cigarettes and anything their heart
而且他实际上在事后签署了一份合同，开始拍意大利西部片。非常帅的家伙。然后劫机者演变成传统的绑架者，索要赎金。开启这一切的是一个叫亚瑟·盖茨·伯克利的人，他是一个失业的卡车司机，和国税局有纠纷，他实际上劫持了一架从菲尼克斯飞往华盛顿特区的飞机，要求最高法院给他1亿美元现金，因为他对最高法院没有受理他的税务案件感到愤怒。所以这就引发了这波流行病的最后阶段，人们开始索要巨额资金、金条、箱装烈酒、香烟以及他们心中想要的
desired. 100,000 in cash, get away, car. And I want the letter M stricken from the English language. And all the while, hijacking was never considered that serious a threat by the airlines, or the passengers, really. It was more that serious a threat by the airlines. Or the passengers really. It was more of an inconvenience than anything else. The assumption on the part of passengers was that, well, we know the airlines will fly us down to Havana.
一切。10万元现金，逃跑车辆。我希望英文字母表里删掉M这个字母。而与此同时，劫机从来没有被航空公司或乘客真正视为如此严重的威胁。这更是航空公司眼中的严重威胁。或者说对乘客来说真的如此。这与其说是一个威胁，不如说是一个不便。乘客们的假设是，好吧，我们知道航空公司会把我们飞到哈瓦那。
The hijack will be taken off the plane, we'll maybe have to spend a night in Havana, we'll be put up in a hotel, maybe buy some cigars and rum for our relatives. And go see the sex show with Frado and Johnny Ola. I see him, that's super name. We'll have a good story to tell at the next cocktail party back in the US. It was taken lightly, because the notion that this could really be something destructive
劫机者会被带下飞机，我们可能得在哈瓦那住上一晚，我们会住进酒店，也许会为亲戚买些雪茄和朗姆酒。然后去看弗拉多和强尼·奥拉的性爱表演。我看到他了，真是个超级棒的名字。我们在回美国的下一个鸡尾酒会上会有一个很好的故事可以讲。人们对它轻描淡写，因为这种事真的会具有破坏性
and turn into mass murder was not something that people's minds at that time. And because the skyjackings weren't especially violent and the passengers weren't yet demanding extra security, the airlines fought to keep things exactly as they were. The airlines were scared. They thought that if they treated all their customers, kind of like criminal suspects because they were merely flying, that people wouldn't fly anymore, that people would drive to their destinations instead.
并变成大规模谋杀的概念，当时并不在人们的脑海中。而且由于劫机事件不是特别暴力，乘客们也还没有要求额外的安全检查，航空公司极力抗争，希望保持现状。航空公司很害怕。他们认为，如果他们把所有的顾客都当作犯罪嫌疑人对待，仅仅因为他们坐飞机，人们就不会再坐飞机了，人们反而会开车去目的地。
So the airlines put up a lot of roadblocks whenever someone, especially in government, mentioned the concept of having physical screening of all passengers. They would shoot that down. Use all their lobbyist muscle to shoot that down. They really forced the FAA's hand to come up with the weakest, most tepid security improvements. The FAA, the Federal Aviation Administration, is the U.S. Government body that is responsible for the safety and regulation of civil aviation. And this was all in the name of, well, we can put up with some hijackings and those cost us, however, 20, 30 grand per hijacking in terms of loss convenience and whatnot.
因此，每当有人（尤其是政府官员）提到对所有乘客进行实体安检的概念时，航空公司就会设置许多路障。他们会驳回这个想法。利用他们所有的说客力量来驳回这一点。他们实际上迫使联邦航空管理局（FAA）拿出了最软弱、最温和的安全改进措施。联邦航空局是负责民用航空安全和规章的美国政府机构。这一切都是以这样的名义进行的：好吧，我们可以容忍一些劫机事件，在损失便利性等方面，这些事件每次劫机大约让我们损失两、三万美元。
Or they could pay millions and millions on X-ray machines, screenings, and security personnel. For the airlines, the smart financial choice was clear. I'll put up with periodic hijackings, comply totally, and keep the customer experience on the ground the same. But clearly something had to be done. If the airlines were unwilling to consider mandatory screening and checkpoints inside the terminals, some less intrusive and somewhat zaneer solutions had to be considered.
或者他们可以在X光机、安检和安保人员身上花费数百万美元。对航空公司来说，明智的财务选择显而易见。我能忍受定期的劫机事件，完全配合，并保持地面上的客户体验不变。但显然必须采取行动。如果航空公司不愿意考虑在航站楼内部进行强制安检和检查点，就必须考虑一些不那么具侵入性且有点荒谬的解决方案。
So, in 1968, the FAA created a special anti-haggacking task force to come up with some solution that would be palatable to the airlines. And they actually opened it up for public comment. They invited the public to submit suggestions about how this could be done. The most common suggestion was complete capitulation. Quote, provide free transportation to Cuba for those persons leaving the United States. End quote. But another tactic that was seriously considered by the Federal Aviation Administration
因此，在1968年，联邦航空局成立了一个特殊的反劫机工作组，以想出一些航空公司能接受的解决方案。他们实际上向公众征求意见。他们邀请公众提交关于如何做到这一点的建议。最常见的建议是彻底投降。引述：“为离开美国的这些人提供免费交通去古巴。”引述结束。但联邦航空管理局认真考虑的另一种策略
was to build a phony Havana airport in South Florida. So the idea is that at this time all the skyjackers wanted to go to Havana, and so you'd kind of just fly them out over the water and then turn back and land at this fake airport and arrest them when they got off the plane was a big idea. It turned out to be too expensive, it cost prohibitive, so they couldn't do that solution. But there were also a lot of the light-full technical solutions whose patents are so much fun to read. There was a hijack rejection seat. There was also one patent for an injector seat, which would have a, quote, hybidermic injection apparatus arranged for driving the needle of a hybidermic syringe
是在南佛罗里达建造一个假的哈瓦那机场。所以这个想法是，在这个时候，所有的劫机者都想去哈瓦那，所以你只需把他们飞过水面，然后折返并降落在假机场，当他们下飞机时逮捕他们，这是一个伟大的想法。事实证明这太贵了，成本过高，所以他们无法实施该方案。但也有很多妙趣横生的技术解决方案，它们的专利读起来非常有趣。有一个劫机弹射座椅。还有一个弹射座椅的专利，它有一个引述：皮下注射装置，用于将皮下注射器的针头驱动
through the seat cushion into the passenger to instantly sedate or kill the passenger. Oh humans, the more you act like Wiley Gaioti, the more I love you. There was a trap door that was patented that would go right outside the cockpit and lock the hijacker in kind of a plexiglass chamber so they could be brought to justice when the plane landed. The public proposed that pilots depressurized the aircraft or expelled sleeping gas throughout the cavern so that everyone falls asleep and the crew would go out with oxygen tanks and
穿过座垫刺入乘客体内，立即镇静或杀死乘客。哦人类，你越表现得像威利·考义特，我就越爱你。还有一个获得专利的活门，可以直接建在驾驶舱外，把劫机者锁在一个有机玻璃室里，这样飞机落地时他们就能被绳之以法。公众提议飞行员给飞机舱内减压，或者在整个客舱释放安眠气，这样每个人都睡着了，机组人员就可以拿着氧气瓶出去，并
disarmed the hijacker. One that I loved actually was giving all the passengers boxing gloves and making them wear boxing gloves the duration of the flight and the theory being that you can't hold a gun if you have boxing gloves on your hands. Of course, then there would be an epidemic of extremely ill-advised boxing matches at 30,000 feet. But the real thing the FAN had going with was this behavioral profile. Now, here's the one thing about the airline terminals. There was one place you had to halt generally, and that was at the ticket agent to get a boarding pass or to
解除劫机者的武装。我其实很喜欢的一个方法是给所有乘客发拳击手套，让他们在整个飞行过程中都戴着拳击手套，其理论是如果你的手上戴着拳击手套，你就拿不起枪。当然，那样的话，在三万英尺高空就会爆发一连串极其不明智的拳击比赛。但联邦航空局真正采用的方案是这种行为侧写。现在，关于机场航站楼，有一点是这样的。你通常必须在一个地方停下来，那就是在售票员那里拿登机牌或
purchase a ticket. There are many more tickets purchased on-site at that time. And that was at the ticket agent to get a boarding pass or to purchase a ticket. There are many more tickets purchased on-site at that time. So this was the one choke point in the terminal experience was the ticket counter. The FAA solution was to train the ticket agents in this 25 behavioral cues that might indicate someone is a potential skyjacker. These were things like not maintaining appropriate eye contact, not caring about your luggage,
购买机票。当时有更多现场购买的机票。那就是在售票员那里拿到登机牌或购买机票。当时有更多现场购买的机票。所以这是航站楼体验中的一个瓶颈，那就是售票柜台。联邦航空局的解决方案是培训售票员掌握25种行为线索，这些线索可能表明某人是潜在的空中劫机者。这些事情包括无法保持适当的眼神交流、不在乎行李、
wearing military surplus gear. And if you saw any of these traits, behavioral traits in a customer coming through to get a ticket or a boarding pass, you would very discreetly ask that they go to a room on the side and be searched. This was not a good solution. The real problem is that ticket agents are not security personnel. They're dealing with hundreds upon hundreds upon hundreds
穿着军队 surplus（剩余物资）装备。如果你在前来买票或拿登机牌的顾客身上看到任何这些特征、行为特征，你会非常谨慎地要求他们去旁边的一个房间接受搜查。这不是一个好解决方案。真正的问题是售票员不是安保人员。他们每天都要应付成百上千个
of often very harried customers per day. And so they're not the people to really identify, even if you assume that these behavioral Q-tip offs work. And it turned out to be a bad assumption because plenty of skydackers passed through without notice. It was meant to be a very low impact solution at the one choke point that already existed in airports and it was really a failure.
通常非常疲惫的顾客。所以他们真的不是识别这种问题的人，即使你假设这些行为线索提示有效的话。事实证明这是一个糟糕的假设，因为许多劫机者在没有引起注意的情况下通过了。这本意是想在机场已经存在的唯一瓶颈处提供一个低影响的解决方案，而它确实失败了。
But the solution that we all know they eventually came up with, screening everybody and their luggage with X-ray machines and requiring ID, all the things that make the airport the horrible place it is wasn't seriously considered until one hijacking changed everything. This is a really forgotten, really pivotal moment in American security history. This is a November 1972 kind of the tail end of this year where there's just been really crazy hijackings went after the next people asking for huge amounts of money. Then you have these three fugitives from the law who hijack a southern airways flight 49. They actually asked to be taken to Detroit. They had a grievance with the Detroit police and they wanted $10 million.
但我们都知道他们最终想出来的解决方案——用X光机对每个人及其行李进行安检并要求出示身份证，所有这些使机场变得糟糕透顶的事情——直到一起劫机事件改变了一切之前，都没有被认真考虑过。这是美国安全史上一个真正被遗忘、真正关键的时刻。这是1972年11月，可以说是这一年的尾声，当时接连发生了一系列疯狂的劫机事件，人们索要巨额资金。然后你有这三个法律逃犯劫持了南方航空公司49号航班。他们实际上要求去底特律。他们对底特律警察有宿怨，想要1000万美元。
And they said if they didn't get it, they were going to crash the plane into the Oak Ridge National Laboratory in their Knoxville, Tennessee. At the heart of that laboratory is actually a uranium-235 reactor. All of a sudden, everyone realized that an airplane could be a weapon of mass destruction. In this case, threatening to turn eastern Tennessee into a nuclear wasteland. And that's really when the light goes on for the airlines and the government that the current situation is no longer tenable. Fortunately, they escaped cataclysm there.
他们说如果拿不到钱，他们就会把飞机撞向田纳西州诺克斯维尔的橡树岭国家实验室。该实验室的核心实际上是一个铀-235反应堆。突然之间，每个人都意识到飞机可能成为大规模杀伤性武器。在这种情况下，威胁要把田纳西州东部变成核废墟。正是在这个时候，航空公司和政府才恍然大悟，当前的局势再也维持不下去了。幸运的是，他们在那里逃过了大灾难。
What happens is the airline doesn't have $10 million, they have $2 million. The high-duckers landed in Chad Nuke, Tennessee to pick up the money. And the high-duckers by that time had actually drunk all the liquor on the planes were completely bombed, and they bring on a high 50 pounds of cash.
发生的事情是航空公司没有1000万美元，他们有200万美元。劫机者降落在田纳西州的查塔努加取钱。而到那时，劫机者实际上已经喝光了飞机上的所有酒，已经完全烂醉如泥了，他们带上了50磅现金。
It's a lot of money, and they think it's $10 million, and so they actually didn't bother to count it. It would have taken them forever to count that much money anyway. No one ever takes that into consideration. The high-jackers eventually landed their plane in Havana, where Cuban authorities captured them. Crisis averted, but surely after that,
这是一大笔钱，他们以为是1000万美元，所以他们实际上懒得去数。无论如何，花那么长时间数钱对他们来说太久了。从来没有人把这一点考虑进去。劫机者最终将飞机降落在哈瓦那，古巴当局在那里抓获了他们。危机解除，但在此之后不久，
you have the executive order mandating Universal physical screen to start on January 5th, 1973 and the airlines put up no fight that time The airlines really wanted the government to provide airport security But the government refused and the airlines hired contractors to do airport screenings and run the metal detectors But the airlines desperately tried to avoid and theyings and run the metal detectors that the airlines desperately tried to avoid. And they put them in January 5th, 1973 and there's literally not a single hijacking in American airspace that year.
你迎来了于1973年1月5日开始强制实行普遍实体安检的行政命令，而这一次航空公司没有进行任何抗争。航空公司真的很希望政府提供机场安检，但政府拒绝了，航空公司雇用了承包商来进行机场安检并运行金属探测器，而航空公司拼命试图避免这一点，而安检在1973年1月5日投入使用，当年美国领空字面意义上没有发生过一起劫机事件。
There were 159 skyjackers in the US from 1961 to 1972 and they really changed the nature of air travel. Even though most of this history is completely forgotten along with the image of the deranged, desperate lone hijacker in military surplus clothing. The public conception of the hijacker changed dramatically in the 80s and response to specifically the TWA hijacking in Lebanon in 1985.
从1961年到1972年，美国发生了159起空中劫机事件，它们确实改变了航空旅行的性质。尽管这段历史的大部分都被彻底遗忘了，穿着军用剩余物资服装的精神失常、绝望的独行劫机者的形象也随之消失。在80年代，公众对劫机者的看法发生了巨大的变化，特别是为了回应1985年黎巴嫩的TWA劫机事件。
And all of a sudden sudden you had hijacking associated with Islamic terrorism, a real kind of scary prospect, something that people didn't understand and was a real boogieman for people at that time. So I think once we kind of had that image, that famous image of the pilot of that plane on the tarmac in Beirut with his captor, with the gun du to his head, leading
突然之间，你把劫机与伊斯兰恐怖主义联系起来，这真是一种可怕的前景，是人们不理解的事情，对当时的人们来说是一个真正的怪物。所以我想一旦我们有了那种形象，那个贝鲁特停机坪上那架飞机的飞行员和他的绑架者、用枪指着他的头、从
out of the cockpit. We completely forgot about these kind of more quaint hijackers who wanted to go to Havana because they had a bad experience in Vietnam. And so I started thinking about more of this really scary crime and a crime of kind of an enemy we don't really understand or know very much about. And so that earlier era was forgotten, papered over, if you will, by this new image of who the hijacker was. And that image remains today, reinforced, of course, by the terror attacks on 9-11, 2001. A date which was preceded by an entire decade free of any commercial
驾驶舱里走出来的著名形象。我们就彻底忘记了这些比较古怪的劫机者，他们想去哈瓦那，因为他们在越南有过糟糕的经历。所以我开始思考更多这种真正可怕的罪行，以及一种我们并不真正理解或了解太多的敌人的罪行。因此，早期时代被遗忘了，或者说被劫机者的新形象粉饰了。而这种形象至今犹存，当然，它被2001年9月11日的恐怖袭击进一步强化了。在这个日期之前，美国领空整整十年都没有发生过任何商业
airline skyjackings in US airspace. After 9-11, the airlines finally got what they lobbied for back when mandatory screenings were introduced in 1973. The government took over security of our nation's airports and created the Transportation Security Administration. The TSA now calls the shots. 99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery, Truppleman, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
航空公司空中劫机事件。911之后，航空公司终于得到了他们在1973年引入强制安检时所游说争取的东西。政府接管了我们国家机场的安全，并创建了运输安全管理局（TSA）。TSA现在掌管一切。《99%隐形》由山姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格、艾弗里·特鲁普曼以及我罗曼·马尔斯制作。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽奥克兰市中心的设计拱门办公室制作。
You can find this show in like the show on Facebook, the staff tweets at Roman Mars, Kitty Mingle, Sam Lissons, and Troublemen. We have a great Tumblr that Avery curates, but right now if you explore our website you will find five dispatches from our image correspondent Kate Joyce who takes amazing photographs based on themes from our favorite episodes. Please do check them out at 99pi.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目，就像这个节目一样，工作人员在罗曼·马尔斯、凯蒂·明格、山姆·里森斯和特鲁普曼那里发推。我们有一个由艾弗里策划的精彩Tumblr，但现在如果你浏览我们的网站，你会发现我们的图片记者凯特·乔伊斯的五份电报，她根据我们最喜欢的剧集的的主题拍摄了令人惊叹的照片。请务必在99pi.org上查看它们。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。